hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and we have a very
fun game that we're going to be going
over today
and that is the nakmansen gamut there's
a few ways that you can
actually arrive at the position of the
nachmans and gambit
most common way that i've seen in my own
games is e45
another three knight c6 and then bishop
to c4 getting into the italian game
followed by knight f6 d4 and then after
they take your castle on
the king side white's gonna be looking
to give up material and the only thing
that white wants in exchange is rapid
development specifically of
the major pieces the queen and the
rookie are going to be heavily involved
into the game and then after knight
takes here on
e4 the key move in the game it is
knight two c three
now i do recognize that they do have to
take the pawn here on a d4 and the
knight has to take
here on e4 for you to be able to play
the documents in gamut so you won't
always get the option
to do this i will make another video if
you would like to see that
feel free to let me know and i will make
a video on the decline lines in case
they don't continue
like we want them to even right here
they could take with their knight here
on c3 we're gonna be covering if they
take with their pawn and this position
is
the best move for them to take with
their pawn but it's also the trickiest
and hardest i think for them to play
we're going to be looking at pawn stakes
here on c3 if you want me to make other
variations
on the decline lines or if they take
what they're not here on c3
feel free to let me know but from here
the main line is for the bishop to take
here on f7 you can see
white's just giving up a ton of material
already gave up of knight here on c3
now giving up a bishop here on f7 after
the king takes
queen comes up here to d5 and has a
very very strong attack now there's no
way for any of the pieces to block
this king here so the king really has
four different options it's going to
come here to a g6
f6 e7 e8 so we're going to look over all
those variations and how
white can best attack the black king
so we will go in counterclockwise first
move you could see is king to g6 seems
like
the worst just if you're looking at this
not sure why they would try to bring
their king
even further out but always like to make
sure that we go over all the variations
in case you see
some terrible moves from here anytime
your queen can come down and your
opponent's king's in the center of the
board
and you can check them and start to
attack i always recommend that so queen
takes here on
e4 check and then from here there's
there's not a lot of great options here
if they play king 2
h5 you can see on the dark squares those
are already blocked off by this bishop
here on c1 so that's going to become
very very important in a lot of these
variations we look at but king to h5
just getting themselves in even more
trouble uh g4
is going to be checkmate if they decide
to come back well this isn't gonna work
either because knight two g5
this is gonna end very very poorly
they're either going to lose their queen
here on a g5 after the bishop takes here
on a g5
or they're just going to lose the game
so king to g8 that's going to lose to
queen d5 that's going to be checkmate or
if they play king 2f6 again anytime your
king is just in the center of the board
and your opponent has so many
pieces involved into the action it's not
going to end well queen 2
f4 king's going to have to come over
here to
g6 and then you just start a massive
attack here
uh pawn up here to g4 preparing for the
queen to come down here to h5
uh there's just no way to stop this
maybe if they try
with g6 uh discovered attack with e6 now
the bishop here on c1 is attacking the
king
and then doesn't matter if they get the
queen involved into the game at
all uh this is eventually going to lead
to uh checkmate so
that's not going to be good coming back
to the very beginning here g6
is going to be a very very poor move at
the beginning
of uh this opening here another option
that you could see
is king 2f6 now this is a pretty tricky
line to
find here the computer does say this is
the best line the black can continue so
we're going to look at a lot of
different ways that white can attack
this
but even though the computer says it's
the best line does not mean a human is
going to find
any of the best moves because who looks
at this and says yeah i just want to
bring my king to the center of the board
and just
let my opponent just tee off and start
to attack all day long
i think it's a pretty difficult way for
black to continue
before we get into white's response if
you haven't already please hit the like
button definitely
supports the channel also lets me know
that you like the snackmansongamit and i
will if we get enough likes make
other videos on the variations for
decline lines
as well as some other accepted lines
that they take with
their knight here on a c3 so if you
haven't already liked the video also
subscribe hopefully if you subscribe to
the channel i know many of you have
uh feel free to hit that bell icon if
you want to be notified anytime i
release
new videos from here white's going to
play rook to
e1 if you can't immediately take with
your queen and check your opponent
it's always good to get more pieces
involved into the game and this puts a
lot of pressure on black
now immediately you can see this knight
here on e4 is under attack now one thing
black may want to try to do is hold on
to this material advantage we gave up a
lot of material we gave up that knife we
gave up the bishop here on f7
but if they try to hold on to the
knights here it's not going to go
well for them so there really are two
options you can see here is
d6 and c5 both of those are going to
lose d6 here
uh watch is going to continue to get
more p's involved into the game and it's
going to end in a checkmate so
uh knight to d6 here bishop to g5 check
can't really come back over here to f7
or the e file because of the queen
and the rook here so it's going to come
to the king side of the board
and eventually in in a checkmate not
here to h4 check
uh bishop here to e7 this is a
discovered attack uh yes you could end
up taking the queen
but it just feels nice telling your
opponent that you don't
have to to win the game those are the
nice moves that i like in chess so yes
you could take here on
uh d8 but this is nice as well so
really from here it's just them blocking
but it's just a waiting move
eventually you are going to to win the
game
queen here to g5 and this is
game over now if we come back instead of
knight 2 d6
it doesn't matter if they played knight
to uh
c5 here it's gonna be the same thing
bishop to g5
at the end this is going to end very
poorly so we've already looked at this
they're going to lose this knight here
it's
pretty much how they're going to
continue from here on out now they could
see
okay maybe we want to play bishop to d6
trying to block off some of the critical
squares that white's going to go to
maybe get the rook involved into the
game here
from here white's going to play rook
takes here on e4
definitely wants to take this material
and get another strong piece of balm to
the action this is also setting up
bishop to
g5 attacking the king it's protected by
the knight here on f3
everything white's doing is supporting
each other and putting a lot of pressure
on black and you can tell from black
standpoint yes they are up in material
but they're just blocked everywhere the
light square bishop's not involved into
the game at all
this rook here on a8 definitely not
involved at all so yes white has given
up material
but they're pretty much just attacking
the opponent king for the rest of the
game
so how does black really continue in
this spot there's no good moves for the
king if he wants to get his rook
involved into the game well this is this
is gonna end poorly this is gonna be a
mate right here bishop to g5
check king g6 knight over here to h4
uh king h5 uh pawn up here to g4 and
this is going to be made so that's not
going to be good if they
recognize that hey the bishop wants to
come up here to
g5 maybe they play h6
but now the threat is going to be after
the knight comes over here to h4 white
is threatening the queen to
f5 and this is a deadly attack here and
so black may try to stop that
and there's a few ways they could do
that the first one would be g6 this
stops the critical square here on f5
but then you could see queen to d3 it's
not an immediate threat but there's so
many
things that white is threatening here
they still can get their dark square
bishop ball into the game the rook can
have a discovered attack here
with the queen coming to g6 so
lot this keeps the threats open for
black and if you look from black
standpoint the queen's still blocked off
the light square bishop's not going
anywhere
anytime they move something like b6
while they're just so far behind in
development getting their rook even
involved into the game isn't
always beneficial now if they come back
and say i don't want to play
g6 because i'm just extending more of my
pawns on the king side of the board it
doesn't really look like it's protecting
it that much
maybe bishop here to e5 this
is protected by the knight recognizing
they may have to give up some material
but then also looking to push forward
with
d6 at some point from now
i like the move rook to f4 and the main
reason i like it is because it almost
looks like you're in preparation mode
especially once you get really good at
neckmanson gambit and you are
playing extremely fast because so far we
should be in bookline for your
preparation because hopefully you watch
these videos and apply it to your games
you don't have to think very much
but it looks like why would we play this
they know
that they could just take here on f4 and
so they may look at it and say i don't
want to take here with my bishop if they
do that's fine we definitely have a
response for that but if they don't
they're going to lose right away so
one of the moves they could try is uh
king to
let's see if they just come here down to
g5 um they definitely come into our
terrorist tour so that's not good but
rook here to
f5 king takes here queen down here to e4
bishop and then this is going to be
checkmate right here
now if we come back and say um all right
what if he doesn't come to
g5 because that seems somewhat
ridiculous but bishop here to e5
rook f4 and then maybe they play
king back here to e7 seems like more of
a safe square but
not really because now white can play
knight to g6 check this is also forking
the rook here on h8 but it doesn't
matter because queen to
f7 this is going to be checkmate so
really they do need to take
the rook here on f4 but that's okay
because that's what we're prepared for
after the bishop takes the queen is
going to come over here to f5
check king moves back here to e7 knight
up here to
g6 this is all sorts of forks attacking
the king bishop and the rook here
after the king comes up here to e8 now
the bishop can take here on
f4 and you still have so many threats
that white has how does black really
continue from here why it's going to be
pushing
his rook over here to e1 all of the
major pieces for white are involved
into the action
now from here the last way they could
stop the queen coming over here to
f5 is if they play knight to
e7 difficult move i think to find but in
this case i would still bring the queen
back here to
d3 now this is all if they play
that bishop to d6 now the computer
thinks the best line
is for black to play knight to e7 i
think this is a near impossible move
unless you've watched this video or
study the the opening in general
uh for black to play yes it is attacking
the queen that's fine
but this blocks the dark square bishop
and the queen
the light square bishop we already know
is blocked the king's in the center of
the board here on f6 this is an
extremely difficult line to find here
because the queen's under attack just go
ahead and take right here you already
have a very aggressive rook here on e1
you're gonna be playing bishop to g5 at
some point
how do they really continue from here
they could try to open up
with their pawn so maybe pawn
to d5 and then you have queen two f4
uh check maybe bishop two f5 blocking
that if they played knight to f5 well
this is a huge mistake because queen
two g5 check and they're going to lose
their queen that's not going to be good
but sometimes they don't know
the best line to do this especially if
you're playing a blitz game or something
you're going to see this knight to f5
move and you're going to capture the
queen here on d8
but let's say they play bishop to f5
okay well that's fine you could probably
not g4 because they have the move queen
to
after g4 they could play queen to d6
which i think is pretty good but the
move you do have
is knight to d4 this still keeps a lot
of the threats that you're looking for
in play you can start to bring your
rook involved into the game uh your
bishop involved you still have your
queen
two g5 at some point eventually you
could play
uh rook up here to uh e6 the bishop is
being pinned down by the queen so
uh knight here to d4 i think is the way
to go if now if we come back a few moves
if they don't play d5 maybe they play d6
same thing queen over here to f4 main
difference is if they play bishop to f5
i think in this case you can play g4 the
queen can't come down here to d6 which i
think is the best variation for black to
continue here
and so white still has a lot of good
threats here
if you look at black standpoint it's
really difficult to look at this and say
i feel really confident in this position
i
i
feel good about winning this even though
they have
a minor piece advantage here this is
tough also you know they could just lose
that because this bishop right here on
f5 is being pinned down
all right so we've looked at king 2 g6
we've looked at king 2
f6 the next version we're going to look
at is king 2
e7 this is a pretty terrible move same
thing as before we're going to go ahead
and take with our queen here on e4
and check and then how does black really
continue here
not a lot of good moves if it comes to
f7
well now knight to g5 uh is
a killer same as we saw before they're
pretty much going to lose their queen
queen comes down we take with our bishop
right here
if they don't they don't have any good
options for their king king here to g8
this
is going to be checkmate and if they
come
down here maybe king 2 f6 well this is
eventually going to lead to checkmate
king to f4
kings would start swinging over to the
kings of the board and the same mating
pattern that we had before
uh this is eventually going to be uh
checkmate so
if we come back and say what if they
don't come to
f7 uh what if after here they play king
to
f6 well now bishop two g5
and this is just losing the queen after
they come here you don't have to take
right away they're still in between
moves because they
have no good way to defend anything
you're doing so queen to d5
check now if they bring their queen back
or king back here to e8 now you can take
their bishop
king to d8 now you could play knight to
g5 just threatening even more moves
knight two f
seven check this is forking the
rook here on h8 you can swing your rooks
get them involved into the action
everything's going to be looking up for
white in this position which leads us to
the last variation
that we're going to be covering in this
video and that is if they play
king 2 e8 now this i think is the most
logical move for black but still it's
not all that great and very difficult
for them to continue now in this spot so
this is the only time where i'm going to
recommend not taking with your queen
here on e4
and instead playing rook to e1 you are
going to capture this material back i
just don't think you need to take it
right away
now the thought is eventually once you
take with your rook you're gonna play
your bishop here to
g5 uh and put a lot of pressure on your
opponent get your other rook involved
into the game so knowing that our bishop
could come here to g5
they could say let's go ahead and stop
at him play an immediate h6
well unfortunately this loses this is
going to be checkmate right away
so keep that in mind you can play queen
two h5
and then after king to e7 then rook
takes here
knight to e5 rook here to e5
uh this is eventually going to lead to a
checkmate they can just chase you around
the board here
um or try to move around so you have to
chase their king around the board
but eventually this is going to end in a
checkmate
pretty cool checkmate if you haven't
checked me your opponent like this in
the game maybe you get a chance if
they try that in the game now h6 is
definitely a mistake here so you won't
see that all too often but something you
could see
is d6 knowing they can't hold on to this
material here on
e4 they may play d6 to try to open up
the board for their light square bishop
to get involved into the game because
for the most part all variations in the
dakminson gamut this bishop here on c8
this rook here on a8 they're not doing
anything but if you see this
first move is go ahead and take with
your rook here on e4 put your
opponent in check and start to attack
now from here
bishop to e7 makes a lot of sense bishop
to g5
attacking the square right here and then
from here you could see a lot of options
maybe they decide to start attacking
here take here on b2
go ahead and bring your rook over here
to e1 just lining everything up on the
e-file if they
come down here take okay that's fine
you're just going to swing your rook
back here to e1
you have so much pressure on your
opponent can be difficult for them to
deal with now if we come back and say
what if they don't take here what if
instead they play h6
well then i would go just go ahead and
take here on e7 that's fine they take
with their knights here you could play
queen
to h5 putting a lot of pressure on your
opponent you're going to be playing rook
here to e1
very very difficult for them to to
continue from here their queen's blocked
off their rook here on a8s not doing
anything
white has a very aggressive stance now
if we come back a little bit more
and say from here what if they play king
2f8 because
maybe they want to have this bishop move
freely and not be pinned down
by this rook here on e4
white's going to continue with rook over
here to e1
and says yeah we want to get our
material involved into the game
we don't really care if you take our
bishop right here because that's going
to lose that's going to be checkmate
because after knight 2 g5
there's no way for black to stop the
checkmate from here the the threat of
queen to
f5 or to f7 is too real
i can go ahead and take the rook here
still threatening the same theme queen
up here to
f7 eventually maybe bishop to e6 they
may have to take with their queen here
but at the end of the day it's all going
to
lose it's going to end up in a checkmate
so if we come back
that was if they played a d6 early on
another thing you could see is okay rook
to e1
i'm just gonna play bishop here to e7
you're still going to take with your
rook here preparing for
bishop here to g5 and there's not a lot
of good ways for them to stop that if
they look at this and say yeah i want to
stop that with h6
this is the critical square here you're
trying to come to you can actually just
take with your bishop here on h6
they can't take with their rook this is
going to be checkmate here on
g8 they also can't take freely with
their pawn here because queen
two h5 king over here to f8
and then rook to f4 bishop has to stop
it here and then
queen to g6 threatening uh taking here
with the rook here
on f6 so maybe d5 opening up for the
light square bishop but then
rook takes here on f6 again so difficult
to stop they're going to lose their
queen
and white's just gonna have a very very
good attack so they can't really stop
the bishop coming here to
g5 here so other options if they play
rook to
f8 well then queen 2 h5 check
if they want to stop this you could take
material here on h7 you're just
destroying their king side of the board
if instead they say we're going to play
d6 trying to open up again you
never know how your opponent is going to
address this but many times you just
want to get material involved into the
game here
well now bishop 2 g5 as we talked about
if they take material same thing you're
going to be coming over here to e1
come down you're going to change
material but eventually going to be
bringing your rook back here to
e1
so that is the nakmansen gamut try to go
over as many variations
that you may come across especially in
the accepted lines
early on if they take with their knights
here
early on i want you to be prepared for
how you're going to continue bishop
takes king takes here
queen comes up here and comes to d5 and
starts the attack
so that's pretty much everything you're
going to see but let me know what you
guys think of
this video and enactments in game try it
out let me know what you guys think it's
always fun to chase your opponent around
the board and there's real no counter
attack there was no lines that we didn't
go over was like well if they do this
one thing they have a pretty strong
attack against your side
white's just going to be attacking and
as long as they know how to continue
with their attack black has
a tough time there's so many mates that
they can fall into if they don't know
the proper line so
thank you guys so much for watching
again if you haven't already please like
the video
uh trying to spread the word about these
fun gambits
especially these uh chess opening videos
that i'm making so thanks for watching
and i'll see you guys in
the next video